at first glance it looks like an
ordinary flash drive however it's
actually a bad USB which can execute
harmful commands let's plug it into a
computer a run window quickly opens we
can see a command that launches malware
from a hacker's server and just like
that the hacker gained access it's clear
that in this case the device is
programmed as a keyboard let's take a
look inside there is an Arduino Pro
micro board it's been programmed to
execute malicious keystrokes thus it's
become a bad USB device and what can a
hacker do steal or destroy the most
important files gain access to devices
connected to the computer install
backdoors for future exploitation even
if you remove the flash drive access
won't be lost given the small dimensions
of the board it can be embedded anywhere
for example in OMG Cable in the keyboard
or in the mouse perhaps the best
protection is specialized software
solutions that allow the connection of
only pre-approved devices from the
whitelist watch the full video through
the link in the comments